ترحيب كبير باحد اهم حلفائه السياسيين
مصافحه حاره وتحيه عسكريه فلاديمير بوتين
اجتمع مع نظيره الصيني
على اجنده البحث تعزيز تعاون المشترك في
مواجهه الغرب
الجمع بين امكانيات روسيا والصين العلميه
والصناعيه سيجعل البلدين رائدين عالميين
في مجال تكنولوجيا المعلومات وامن شبكات
والذكاء الاصطناعي
يتعين على الجانبين تدعيم الاتصالات
والتنسيق الوثيق لتعزيز تنميه جديده واكبر
للتعاون للعملي بين البلدين
بقلب هذا الاجتماع وتحديدا الخطه التي
طرحتها بكين الشهر الماضي وتدعو موسكو الى
الانخراط في محادثات سلام
نعتقد ان العديد من النقاط في خطه السلام
التي اقترحتها الصين تتماشى مع النهج
الروسي
ويمكن ان تكون بمثابه اساس لتسويه سلميه
للصراع
لكن عندما يكون الغرب هو كياف على استعداد
لذلك
امر لم نلحظه حتى الان
ادانت الولايات المتحده هذه الزياره امر
لن يمنع استمرار التعاون الروسي الصيني
دعا بدوره فلاديمير بوتين الى زياره الصين
هذا العام الدعوه تاتي في وقت صدرت فيه
مذكره توقيف بحق الرئيس الروسي الاسبوع
الماضي من الجنائي دوليه